many of America's largest retailers
including Amazon now plan to stop
selling all paint stripping products
containing a deadly chemical we've
reported on throughout the year an
advocacy group claims at least 64 people
have died since 1980 from exposure to
paint strippers containing methylene
chloride the EPA proposed banning the
chemical in 2017 but so far that
proposal has gone nowhere we told you in
January about a new safer formula in
development a new product is expected to
be on the market in the US soon and a
Werner has been investigating this story
all year long Anna good morning good
morning Tony well we've reported how
three young men died while using these
products since April of 2017
the EPA still has not taken action and
yet another mother lost a son says she
won't stop pushing until the agency does
get a smile that lit the sky he was very
generous he was very kind-hearted this
Christmas wasn't the same for Lauren
Atkins Josh Lewis story needs to be told
last February her 31 year old son Joshua
died while using paint stripper in a
bathroom to refinish the fork from his
BMX bike that's when I went up and
knocked on the door and he didn't
respond so I opened the door I felt he
was gone had been gone for several hours
when you learned that there were other
mothers with sons I was heartbroken
because none of these deaths needed to
occur all of these were preventable
Joshua Atkins joined victims Kevin
Hartley and drew Wynn who both died in
2017 all young men who lost their lives
using these common strippers containing
methylene chloride there's no need for
this to be on shelves the chemical is so
dangerous
EPA's own scientists decided it should
be banned for all consumer and most
professional uses saying it posed an
unreasonable risk but that was a year
ago and still no action from the EPA
so Atkins and the other mothers plan to
sue the EPA next month I can't
you to fight for the band I continue to
speak out can we banded together and
we're gonna continue to be together
until our voices are heard and until
this is off the shelf the Environmental
Defense funds Richard Dennison says
those deaths were avoidable and the EPA
must do more it can't cut corners it
can't start creating loopholes that
allow the industry to escape the intent
of this rule which is to ban these uses
and protect consumers as well as workers
we are concerned that one corner they
might cut is to try to exempt from this
ban
commercial uses of these chemicals but
some aren't waiting for the government
to act in January we showed you how
scientists at the University of
Massachusetts toxics use Reduction
Institute developed an alternative they
say is safer and works just as well
research manager Greg morose showed us
we've got to read latex top coats on a
test board painted with several coats
and baked at high temperatures to
simulate real-life conditions he
demonstrated the team's new solvent it
worked and now a Canadian company has
announced its producing a new product
using that alternative formulation the
goal is to have it available in every
major hardware and paint retail chain in
the United States Canada and Mexico we
feel it's a great option to have on the
shelves for every retailer in addition
major chains including Lowe's Home Depot
Walmart and online retailer Amazon now
say they will begin phasing out
methylene chloride based strippers by
year's end the changes should save lives
even if they come too late for Joshua
Atkins
you know we have three mothers and when
you mess with our kids you're in trouble
the primary manufacturer of the
strippers with methylene chloride has
been critical of the researchers new
alternative in the past they point out
it is flammable and they say it too is
toxic the researchers say the solvents
in their formulation however don't close
quote
immediate death from high exposures like
methylene chloride can and that alone
they say makes the new product much less
hazardous that product by the way is
expected to hit store shelves here in
the US any day they say it's ready for
distribution it seems insane that people
have ruled already that this should not
be on store shelves and that it still is
right that's the EPA's own scientists
the EPA says it's a problem should be
banned but the EPA hasn't taken action
correct so a lot of these environmental
groups along with the mothers are
preparing to file suit against the EPA
in January to make that happen
Anna Warner thank you so much